just got married last year got married
thank you
we did all of our own decorations at the
wedding one of the things we did to save
money was this Japanese tradition where
as a couple you fold 1,000 paper cranes
and if you're able to finish by your
wedding day you're supposed to have good
luck throughout your marriage we did an
Americanized version of the Japanese
tradition where the man folds 995 paper
cranes and then the woman folds five
shitty unrecognizable paper cranes now
for the rest of our lives we're gonna
tell everyone that we folded 1,000 paper
cranes I hope that the amount of luck
that we have in the marriage is
proportionate to the amount of cranes
that we folded for that afternoon I
don't know why the ceilings only leaking
from your half of the bed maybe you
should have folded more cranes I don't
know why only your half of our plane is
crashing my half is being suspended by
magic paper cranes we are late to
everything we're never on time it's a
problem for us as a couple it's gotten
to a point now where if we fit to be
somewhere at 6 my wife will tell me we
have to be there at 5:30 in order to
trick us into being on time and it never
works and the reason why it doesn't work
is because I am NOT the problem that's
five doesn't work all tricking me does
is make me mad for an extra half hour
every time relate to something we're
running late to the movies I went to
check on our shoots of painting your
fingernails
my initial response was anger it's dark
in the theater no one's even gonna know
what you did we we could paint your face
before we head out and no one would know
about it
but I don't say anything it's my wife
that's the woman that I picked although
all the other women on the planet to
spend my life with and she feels more
beautiful and confident with those
fingernails painted and I guess I'm
gonna miss those previews I guess I
guess that's the life that I live now I
live a life where I never know what's
coming soon to a theater near me
that's something I don't get to know and
then I like to see what color she's
painting her fingernails and she was
painting them clear and then my brain
exploded are you even doing anything or
are you pretending to paint your
fingernails I can't tell if you need me
I'll be in the front yard mowing it with
a bubble maker let me know when you're
ready I have so many bubbles to pop
she's only makes him shinier if that's
all you needed we could have just got
popcorn at the theater right one large
popcorn extra napkins no Butler opposite
of that would make more sense said it
wrong everything shoes ones late to
watch Netflix in our own home you are
breaking the laws of space and time
right now Netflix starts whenever you
want we picked out a movie together and
she goes don't start it yet I have to go
to the bathroom and then a half hour
later I'm still sitting there like where
did she go
I went to look and she was in the shower
so I confront her I was like why would
you take a shower when I was out here
staring at a red screen by myself
waiting on you and she looked me in the
face and she goes I'm not taking a
shower I'm rinsing off and that is how
my wife beats me in arguments she she
just denies that she's doing the thing
that I'm mad about and I don't know how
to fight back against someone that does
that I have 35 years of life experience
leading me to believe that what I'm
seeing right now is called a shower you
just said it wasn't I don't know where
to go from here yes huh
you're in a shower there's water hitting
you it seems like a shower if you are
rinsing off you be in a colander and
I'll be holding you under the sink
bunch of grapes just trying to get the
pesticides off you before I pack tea up
in my kids school lunch she does it to
me all the time doesn't participate in
the argument we're on a road trip once
she fell asleep I was like sweetie you
got to wake up I'm sleepy too
I need someone to talk to me so we can
arrive at our destination safely and she
goes I'm not asleep
I'm resting my eyes
are you also airing out your throat well
hi
why has your mouth been open for the
last 15 miles was it too wet back there
too much moisture in the old esophagus I
don't think it's fair I want to use the
technique against her like oh you're mad
that I'm drunk right now well guess what
I'm not drunk I've just raised my blood
alcohol content so that I could have
more fun of this Thanksgiving this is a
science experiment that you're
witnessing right now I'm trying to see
how I can raise my blood alcohol content
until I have to rest my eyes on your
mother's sofa thank you very much guys
[Applause]
you